aber es ist man muss kohle induction
feldes tun oder für kohl dass dafür auch
noch sehr viele andere sachen die für
quantum leggins brauchst du hier macht
mir auch den nächsten ich finde jetzt an
dann machen wenn man zusammen dafür
brauchst du ganz viel iridium
allerdings zeigen wann turnhosen
brauchst du hier brauchst iridium macht
die region platten die machst du aus
vier iridium ein ihr video ist viel viel
viel viel viel selten jemand das heißt
möglich machen könnte nachdem zu einem a
stranger und so weiter ist ziemlich
teuer
ich brauche meine ganze nur für das dann
quasi das heißt ich habe etwa fünf bis
zehn folgen frühestens und ich bin
glaube ich ziemlich in dem bereich gut
ausgebaut
das heißt diese folge schätze ich die
chancen auf eine quatro sie ziemlich
gering ein unendliches und zwei mal auf
so glaube ich so wartet man den ganzen
scheiß sachen die ich hier wieder geholt
habe da rein so liebenswert zu sein geht
es eigentlich jemand andersfarbigen
verwendet hier hier und hier ja das geht
meist in gibt es in zwei farben und wir
haben keinen anderen unterschied nur
andere farbe von das irgendwie ja das
ist bei dings ja auch so bei kopf stellt
sich bei kummer auch vollauf ja das volk
ab mit dieser unterschiedliche farben
aber gleiche dings server batterien
ich fand es noch mehr zielwasser nämlich
selber ich brauche das von ihm und sport
das ordentlich glaube ich nicht dass er
noch monster hoch kommen so müller
die batterie ist mir in dem fall schon
drei elektrische macht elektroantrieb
und chain store in folge elektriker
mittlerweile geworden
du siehst du auch aus so warte da kommen
jetzt keine mops vorher das schon mal
gut mach ich das hier vorne jetzt auch
eben zuletzt ein bisschen bei mir ja ich
bin ein roboter von beruf das ist okay
ist auch elektrik in dem fall und auch
keiner hoch glaub ich mich wieder auf
mich schnell sogar bei rauskommt manier
wird sich etwas teurer na ja mach mal
kurz was jetzt geht's wieder direkt
ausprobieren ob das gut geht jetzt habe
ich noch richtig
90 runter so doll die wetter gehen war
übertrieben die blätter gehen verdammt
schnell weg
wieso geht und das ist gar nicht da hab
ich ja gesagt lohnt sich wo muss ich
noch mal das kostet verdammt der
regierung besser weg macht aber du
kannst auch holztage weg machen damit
muss ich jetzt mal den gast rein tun
damit ich doch als er zu bekommen
beim major wird empfehlen einen rot
terry melcher zimmer habe ich habe ich
aber jetzt wo ich das 3 1 thun soll eben
beim essen hätte aber ich habe schon die
herzen drin also nicht hoffen natürlich
hielt aber ich hasse das meint man ofen
wird einfach immerhin 0 prozent der
braucht jahre um warm zu werden dann
macht ihr einen lover dann macht auch
gleich kurz schauen wie es geht naja
stimmt dass ein lehrer daran ist genial
es ist glaube ich trotzdem kurz wieder
anfängt zu legen
oh ja ok ruf anteilen der jetzt hier
nichts ist so komisch wie mache ich ein
leather
muss kurz anrufen moment theron eckig
ruft hey hey was geht so vielleicht
nicht mehr das geht jetzt denkst du bei
mir bisschen aber das egal
wie mache ich einen schalter nachbarn.de
finde ich ja nicht gibt es ein level
finde ich nicht schockmoment hier gibt
es hier keinen schalter
doch da doch jeder hebel heißt er bei
mir auch so jetzt das auf deutsch
gestellt deswegen zählen cobblestone und
ding ist aber nicht größte so den dänen
den platz ehe ich jetzt einfach hinten
allerdings genau einfach nicht bei der
ausgabe also nicht bei speziellen ende
keystone kann ich beim beim major auch
machen oder da hinten noch einer dran
also ich war jetzt aber auch nicht zu
viel energie aber schnell
sie ist auch sehr schnell wieder energie
das ist natürlich blöd so dann kommt da
noch dass kopper dingsbums reinwarth
wenn ich doch kuba und in ihr
zusammentun dann kriege ich bronze
kupfer und 10 genau
witzig wenn sie zwei leute aufnehmen die
einfach was komplett unterschiedliches
machen und sich damit ein ander
unterhalten
ist doch gut wenn uns jetzt geben das
ist bisher in allen aufnahmen einfach
bei mir so gewesen wie segment detektiv
aus wieder in rage
jetzt mache ich noch immer schnell
verlässt
in der jetzt in doug schnell völlig okay
würde ich auch empfehlen würde das
gehört einfach ich habe mit deutschen
firmen wie du bist mir so überrascht
auch haben will auch haben will kommt
mir vorbei ist nicht schwer
kannst du bei mir echt auf die
handlichen electrique wenn es erstmal
okay mit firnis electric red
und letzter man braucht nur einen davon
stimmt ich hab vergessen letzte mit
zudem völlig vollidiot aktuell webseiten
haben
wer nett ja dann der 31 geben dann habe
ich hab nicht denken
machen wir 15 15 15 für 26 also
halbe-halbe ein halber preis halbe das
angebot dass ich meine du willst 15
für 26 kohle ja verlierst und tim kann
ich was macht verdoppeln hier quasi 7
hat hin
danke dass du musst dich dich bist danke
nödl doch ich will also aus dem kann ich
kann die diamant machen aber aus kohle
schon von daher erhält er machen sind
für mich das macht ihn hallendach fasste
seine farm ist ja und 8 nein ich dachte
vielleicht wieder gleich macht dann hat
er keine kühle habe ich gehört oder nee
das ist aber relativ egal weil das
kraftwerk ist gut isoliert oder ihn
gedacht
von daher ist das relativ egal und auch
wenn es in der luft ihm würde hätte es
höchstens power und seinen grundstücken
nun doch zu kriegen um die luft das
heißt wenn die luft fliegt dann er
das ist schön und so ganz denn lena dann
kommt voll holt und dann dachte mein
schönes kaputt dann lache ich auf jeden
fall aber ich habe ihn gewarnt
der ist fast fertig da sind noch mehr
körper so dann werde ich mich jetzt erst
mal froh 12 landsleute skype in das
anders
nein ich möchte jetzt moment moment
moment so kohl genau jetzt brauche ich
kohlen läuft aber ist man muss kohle
induction feldes tun oder für kohl das
cold as ice age stimmt genau deren hohle
komm raus holen ihr eine freundin die
nicht wissen was ich jetzt gerade mache
ich ein praktikum da rein macht daraus
dann carbon kohle stärker daraus mache
ich keinen platten daraus mache ich dann
auch noch einen ball und daraus kann man
diamanten kräften und die diamanten
brauche ich wenn es darum geht es nicht
der stick dem fc kaputt dass man es hier
kurz im wiki nebenbei nach dass es
besser geworden mittlerweile dass alle
sich immer mehr mehr damit beschäftigen
alle aus alu place
er macht ihn noch gar nichts wäre wenig
zerstört
jetzt sollte die energie eigentlich
nicht mehr unternehmen bleibt an geil
begeistert war kaplan circuit ist dass
ich habe nur so einen komischen electric
circus habe ich den noch mal habe ich
gar nicht ich habe verzauberung tisch
aber kann ihn nicht platzieren weil ich
so viele bücher ab achja zucker aber
kannst du mir da einfach was abgeben
damit meine farm bisschen schneller
wächst der frage nach ob ich bei ihm
bisschen was wegnehmen kann
machen wir daraus jetzt sie kohle
platten so so so so so so runter da
zeigt kann jetzt rasch so was darf ich
von denen zucker euro zu haben
aber wie viel halt der die oberen zwei
reihen konzern massaker dazu dass es
nach rechts quasi bei mir ist es immer
der hat jetzt nämlich gerade auf und
jetzt sehe ich wo wir sind schon bei 25
minuten gerade jetzt ja da denke ich mir
sogar ein mann am liebsten würde ich
noch viel länger einfach weil ich noch
übels viel noch machen möchte einfach
mit solchen wegen regens ist
mittlerweile wahrscheinlich aber ich
auch gerne wissen mehr aufnehmen
mittlerweile ich bin ja auch nicht so
krass befürworter der regel aber sie ist
in einer gewissen weise halten am besten
für alle mitglieder
deswegen müssen wir die mehr oder
weniger akzeptieren und wir leute wenn
ihr müsst jetzt nicht uns helfen wenn
ihr wissen wollt dann eigentlich gar
kein aber massiver dann folgten ein spaß
das ist auf jeden fall das ist nicht
unsere idee gewählt also das war das war
nein das war schon unsere idee aber
einverstanden muss wirklich wenn ihr
wollt ja auch nicht dass wir nachher
euer lieblings youtuber dazu kommt sagen
wir mal das es zum beispiel captains
wackelt wenn er dann nachher bei mega
projekt mitspielt und er fängt hier auf
null an und wir sind alle bei folge 1000
und debatten des beispiels wird ja
irgendwann so sein aber wenn wir alles
erstarrt und auf einmal prescht einer
davon mit 1000 folgen und alle anderen
sind sollten wir sind normal wir laden
nicht so viel hoch aber trotzdem ist der
fall wenn wir mit ihm spielen weil hier
drauf oder sodann
dann ist das schon ein bisschen
ärgerlich jetzt events stehen zum abbau
jetzt gar nicht lost its way to say that
enable richtung kult ist
das hier lag trek fans
wenn man jetzt lieber einen
fahrzeuganhänger was kommt jetzt auch
einen hamburger isst einfach meine farm
ihr sohn uhr nachts sind ihr vorher so
einfach auf jeden fall hat man eine
menge zucker war die sache freunde bei
mir die haben es besser
bei mir wird noch alles schön auf dem
grundstück sagen sie alle
nein also ich habe mich schon pläne ich
kann euch kurze foto einblenden habe ich
nehme kann ich nicht also ich glaube
dass
fast effekt ist ein after effects
services nein ich bin so doof ich bin zu
lüften zu dürfen ein dass alles am
renntag auf nein das sind echt richtige
after effects so dann packe ich hier
noch zuckerrohr hin wechselt meine
kleinen freunde erwartet meine freunde
seine baumfreunde gebäude pflanzen nein
bei mir nicht einen drauf gesetzt
nämlich nicht dement grundstück sieht
echt so 085 coolness immer einen
draufsetzen
ein grund schickt einfach so 08 15 uhr
das unglaublich traurig ich habe auch
noch ein leder er ich brauche ganz viel
leder für bücher die ganze küche sind
einfach total bücher haben ja ich hab
leider nur 56 ich hab's geschafft ein
buch viele brauchst du ich brauche so
viele dass ich mir meinen enchantment
table so machen kann dass ich da auf
höchstem level entscheiden kann
zwölf bereichen wie sowas als soviel
brauchst du auch so was wie die regale
direkt du bist mir aber ein gieriger du
typischer gieriger ein hub 60
der nette nachbar kommt eben vorbei ja
aber mit der kettensäge wir können
auftreten wenn du willst das ganze in
verkaufen stößt gucken einfach meine
kiste ich hab ne menge kopf eine menge
silber eine menge apatit leben handelt
er voll viel aber ich hab ich gar nicht
eins zu eins
danach hätten sie gekommen um ein
grundstück von unserer bücher ja was
willst du noch haben das alles 360 zu
haben das ist klar kiste um kiste ja
dass auch ich überhaupt